[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bourgeois ils en
font un drôle de bruit ce soir nicolas
et pimprenelle on se croirait aux 24
heures du mans au ce quoi c'est là qu'a
lieu une grande course d'automobiles
je me plais patron je veux je veux
comprendre
entre eux soit prudent nounours regarde
la mienne va plus vite
où était la mienne à moi elle à moteur
sans médaille écoute moi a beau voir le
gros hors autos regarde comme elle est
jolie ma voiture et elles gagnent tous
les plans le mieux nos ciel qu'à une
honte
elle fait le tour de la maison plus que
celle de pimprenelle elle fonce regarde
[Musique]
1 à la chaussée du dimanche vers nous
ils me laissent pas d'oublier
on te plains jamais encore madame et
votre code de la route 1 1
alors tu mets ce passé à trac dans
l'impression qu'un agent de police
devraient surveiller ces routes
oui mais c'est l'agent de police je
crois que ma voiture allait en panne
alors je ne suis pas buter liste yeux
mais un agent de police
c'est là pour rendre service
voyons au juste une heure ou deux
peuples et où là vous pouvez rouler mon
garçon
elle a bon dos tout sauf aux autres
votre droite
ah bon vous avez un permis de conduire
mais bien sûr chez monsieur l'agent fous
circulent et se femme on voit l'eau
vous vous êtes fait pour moi j'arrive en
même temps vous êtes de petits as du vau
l'eau
bravo messieurs le champion bravo pas
moins la championne allons mettez votre
voiture au garage
il est l'heure pour les champions
d'aller au lit par les agents de police
aussi bien sûr je le suis de service que
de vous
il est
[Musique]
because la police
bonne nuit scharrach à adnane peau de 10
mai d'un fonds non la lune
deux bonbonnes huit grands champions
bonnier grande championne tort bien vous
aussi mes chers petits amis faites comme
nicolas et pimprenelle aller vite au
dodo embrasser bien fort vos parents le
feu de beaux rêves
cevher patron on peut y aller banani à
deux mains
[Musique]